so welcome again to PI data yeah now it
is working well I wear several hats one
of them is at Berkeley Lab where I'm the
computation research division and other
hat is as a data scientist at the
berkeley institute for data sciences is
it's at UC Berkeley we're also Flavio
rose you and homeware e Silva which are
here with me are visiting as visiting
professors so today we're going to talk
about image processing computer vision
related problems within the idea of a
content-based image retrieval or subvert
and that also is part of the package
that we've been putting together call
Pais I beer and the main idea is to be
able to do queries using pictures
themselves so why is it complicated it
seems that we're able pretty quickly to
sift through pictures automatically
right and this was completely automatic
so I had a picture of my daughter for
the past ten year within the last 10
years and with that one I was able to
recover pictures from the last 10 years
and constructed this mosaic so systems
for retrieving pictures based on the
content of the pictures particularly
human faces are very good right now both
Facebook are is an example as well as
Google photos besides a human faces also
human behavior and start being tracked
so there's there are a lot of tools on
that so what's new about what we're
trying to put in the spice a beer that's
what we're going to talk today I'm going
to present a quick introduction what
severus are when they started the make
the main pillars of sabur our signatures
similarity and retrieval another pillar
in enabling a sub
system is to have a human interaction so
we're going to present the gooey
associate to that it show a few
experiments running the stool in real
data so here are some of the large data
sets that we were user to so far and
then present a few ideas and perhaps you
want to be a contributor of this new
package that we're being putting
together so what are these pictures
basically this is something that you
know how to do since you're one year old
and it seems that computers are is to
challenge which is to compare a shape
with another shape and even collar and
so on so that this is part of the
problems that we're going to see into
their how the system works we present a
picture and we expect that the following
pictures are closer to this one so sabur
is just one of the names for systems
that are able to retrieve pictures based
on the picture itself another name cubic
query based information up content it's
actually query by image content and
other acronyms so if you want to google
around that these are some of the
acronyms that you may want to know but
basically what he uses this computer
vision pattern recognition and a lot of
machine learning what's the main
difference from what you're currently
doing your search instead of using
metadata which are keywords and tags
you're eating study using properties of
the picture itself such as color shape
and texture and the goal is actually to
bridge the gap between the image content
the image properties and the human
queries you want to be able to do that
much faster and I'm using higher level
information when did it start 1992
toshikazu katoh and was perform a few
experiments using pictures to retrieve
pictures in a database ranking them in
invented the term and 9 in
292 sipper I'm sure if we were trying to
do that before but the concept was
actually introduced them and only in 94
we have the first commercial system
proposal by IBM and of course besides
proposing the commercial system they
also proposed a new acronym so that's
when cubic came up where are we now
we're very good at collecting data by it
by any means we big data came out of
this ability of being able to collect
the data but how we're query this data
we can do a find in your our whatever
system you you're doing your locate any
you can use tags to retrieve related
information document most of the systems
I'm sure most of the laptops that you
have in here are not able to query based
on images itself so that's what we will
like in particular for a scientifically
images so different from the images up
front from images up faces we would like
to use images of microscopes or
telescopes if you will and be able to
collect to bring other pictures that are
very very similar to those so we're see
you we still have a lot of work to do in
terms of organizing to be able to
retrieve information using pictures
themselves just in case you're curious
so you don't need a Google I did that
for you there is a collection of a
different severus search engines and
you're going to notice that a very
stunning minority here will be open open
stores these zippers live inside
projects you're going to notice that
also a small part of them are GPL so our
dream as we were inspired by Tracy this
morning in folks run software carpentry
data carpentry and Jupiter itself is to
create tools that are available in open
sources so we will like this to be as
well
just an example of a few tools I
actually got the chance to play with
them notice there's no maintains to the
most of them so why buy a beer we want
to make inspired by folks front for
example for an eye Piketon we really
very close to for another press and one
of the dreams is to that this do as well
python based tool can live in ecosystems
that have a community built around it
and help us to put together this new
tool for content-based image retrieval
so that we can query by example we just
use a picture to retrieve similar
pictures and allow general purpose
investigation across different image
domains and why would we the three of us
be interest on that that's our daily
basis job we as computer vision experts
need to deal with well today we're
waking up and breakfast microscopy of
cancer cells and tomorrow it's going to
be CT Emma and the other day is going to
be MRI of brains and the other day is
going to be pictures scanning electron
microscopy of new film story electronics
so we need such a system ourselves in
order to do a better job and to recover
those those those are processing is that
we call a test 1 test 2 okay so in those
in those circumstances if you try to
find using just the tag or a keyword
very hard you're not going to be able to
but if you want to query using all at
one of pictures that have circles
associate in bring me back my
experiments to have a bed of beads then
that that will be very helpful again
we're going to be exploring color
texture shape as part of the system as
well as learn signatures using CNN for
those that are not familiar the stands
for convolutional neural networks and
deal with a several similarity and in
this case because these signatures are
just feature vectors so transformation
of a pic
to a feature vectors we use the
similarities just a distance between
these vectors we're going to show you
different flavors of calculating those
metrics in a nutshell how the system
works so that you yourself can be part
of the team so at night hopefully you're
relaxing and a turret remember to turn
off your monitor the image database is
explored by this first module that is
turning this large image database into a
much smaller database containing just
the signature so right here we have data
reduction and I'm saying overnight
because this is going to take a while
particular if you have very large data
sets so um you want to slides that I
showed us so so far is one of the things
that I will use it is so far we use an
image Annette on the training part of a
one up and we're going to show details
on that so hang on so you would we wake
up that morning and guess what new
images appeared and we want to make sure
wow do I have experiments with this kind
of cells perhaps these are brand new
cells and you know we're going to get
the Nobel Prize for them or perhaps we
just have those are not in our data sets
they're very common cells nothing new
without it you want a query using the
sells itself so we're not actually going
to query this big guy but instead we're
going to query this is smaller data
reduced database only with the
signatures or a feature vectors so the
pictures in the query are transformed in
to feature vectors or signatures so then
we calculate distance in rank all of
those pictures that are more similar to
these than any others in a database and
with that we're gonna I went to roughly
which are those two boxes and that's
what rom will explain and then Flavio
will give you a demo of the pick up the
tool itself
and ask you again no single vector
perfect so the question is what's the
signature this is a feature vector that
represents each of the pictures that we
have in the database so basically you
transform your image in color or
intensity is only or a 3d you name it
into one feature vector with the several
attributes so i'm home i receive and now
i will talk a little about the future
extraction methods that we use the
impasse IP or this how to compute these
signatures so we use a toad office five
different ways you can put these
signatures they are the grade level
committee matrix the histogram of your
entity gradients the first you are the
texture features and the local binary
partner and at the end the convolutional
neural network or CNN so the first one
is the grade level co-occurrence matrix
and we will see from now the locus of
each package of the each match that you
we used in this case we use the psychic
image package for Jael CM so the basis
of jealousy m is to compute how many
times a pair of pixels occur in an
imaging in fact an imaging is josie a
matrix of values and each value
corresponds to a color or an intensity
for example this image in figure 1a is a
four by five image with intensity values
between 1 and h so what jealousy n do it
is count all currencies of pixels in an
image for example the pair of pix 11
occur only once and discounting will be
storage
in on 2d histogram that you called gel
cm for example the 11 occur only once
then we will start this value at the
line 1 and column one with the count 1
they want to occur twice and we will
start this very the position 1 and
column 2 with value too okay so using
this to Jerusalem we can put some
features and they are the Contra see the
similarity homogeneous energy
correlation and the glass second moment
also jedziemy is has been used in
several applications from it medical
images to scientific material so the
next one is the histogram of your into
the gradients yes this is a parameter of
the discrete you can you can use it this
way is Z 0 degree or you can use a 9
degree is a parameter 45 okay so the
next one is the histogram of your entity
gradients jeez this descriptor basically
com puts the magnitude in the directions
of intensity variations in an image for
example here in fig reach away we have
an image from the describer textual data
set that is a public data set and here
we have all day all day gradients
computed that means that the variation
of intensities of the image and what we
did is judge can put an histogram of
this image and this is the final vector
of this dismantling so this kind of
descriptor is is highly Lucifer object
detection like position and vehicles and
the reason is that similar objects has
similar intensity variations so the next
one
the first two other textual features and
this is also know as histogram features
and the pie site build compute they
computes the histogram of the image and
inside this histogram we can put these
sixth metrics that they mean the valency
skewness kurtosis energy and entropy and
this kind of dispute oh I'm sorry this
kind of descriptor is used mostly in
brain and lung tumor detection so the
next one is the local binary partner or
LBP and the basic is out of LBP is to
make an image binary basic on its
central pixels in this case is 65 so we
will compare all the pixels with the
central one if it if the neighbor was
greater than 65 each will be marketed as
one in a thresholding image otherwise it
will be marketed as zero in distress
holding imaging with this we obtained in
binary number and we convert this binary
number to a decimal one so we did this
process for all the pixels of the image
and the final step is to compute the
histogram of this decimal numbers and so
the logo banner pattern is usually for a
face detection motion and also to text
to characterization so the last one is
the convolutional neural network in this
case we use the two packets the tensor
flow and the piano and the a CNN is a
sequence of convolutional layers fully
connect the layers and one output layer
the most common way to use CNN is to
classify all or two segments images but
we do not use the same Ian in the most
common way we remove the output layer
and we use the other future is computed
in the convolutional layers
and photo conductor layers as signature
for our PI cell bill also the pass I
bill can use the CNN in two different
ways trendy with the same database of
the image retrieve in this case we use
to congressional layers or trendy with
the CNN exception geez CNN exceptions is
on training data set a trend CNN I'm
sorry that was trained you using the
image net the database the image net has
a million images and is divided in 1000
class in this case the CNN inception use
see sex convolutional layers also we can
notice that the using the first the
first approach we have more accurate
results and but they they compute the
training timing was very high in
relation to the second one so now that
you know how to compute the signatures
we have to compare these signatures to
know how similar are two images and to
do this we we use the 10 different
distance mattress or similarity matrix
and they are they up Lydian day off
infinity cost n person ki square Kubek
liberal divergency Jeffrey como para
crime ever miss and switch block
distance so we use this thing ten
different ways because they are the most
common in cyber papers also using
different metrics we can have
differentiy ranked at the output so that
is the equation of each one of these
this mattress in this case we use the
site by package okay so the input of
each equation is an x and y X is the
signature of a Kurian imaging and why is
the signature of an imaging of the data
the data set and the output your future
equation is a
so awesome if you have for example and
an image data set within a small in tech
class difference you you probably use it
the cool but Liberty divergence this one
so this one instead of the Allegiant
distance in so four different data sets
we you you probably use different Jesus
mattress so now flat will you talk a
little about the device I build is
touching how to organize the data set hi
my name is flat Vera wool and as her
mother todos I will talk about how to
use the PI sigh beer there are two
versions of the buy side beam that are
by using command line in bios and
graphical interface and for both
versions it is necessary that the father
of the root folder of the database has
to be organized as this figure shows in
this figure each blue a blue box
represents a ford and EG yellow box
represents an image basically the image
has to be organized in folders inside
your database folder and after they
achieve your profs for the pass i build
a csv file will be safe inside your
pictures folder and the result will be
saving Savior results folded this is the
graphical interface of the pie ciebie
infras you have to set the path for the
root database the root folder of the
database then the name of the class and
the number of images for each class will
be showing the box number two then you
can choose the future education method
that will be using in the number in the
box number 3 after each you are so
enthused adjacency that you will be use
it in the achiever process
anything box number 5 you have two
options you can do the retrieval process
for a single Curie image Oh for a lot of
images inside a folding you just need to
set the path now I you show a short
video that shows the how the PCB works
and also as I told you also that is a
version in using command line and in
this version you just need to set the
paths of the database and they had to
view image and also you have to choose
the feature a station methods and a
decent that you abused as I told you in
the first step you have to set the path
for the database in this example I'm
using a fibrous database database and
this database has 4,000 image in this
example I will was the convolutional
neural network and for each method that
is as such as set of parameters and if
you don't want to set the parameter it's
ok the pie Siberia was the default for
each method and after I will keep the
equation Jesus in this example and now I
have to choose the path for Dave for the
Curie image in this example I'm using 6
image 6 security image and also I have a
UH apartment that is the number of head
rivet image in this example I will
achieve the top 9 for each Curie image
and I have to wait for some seconds
while they proceed the head river cross
and for big data bits they disperse can
be Larry lot longer and after each the
results is safe inside of the result for
them and this is the result and the sex
Curie images are in the first column for
each image we have the top 9 head rivet
in image inside of the database
because at the moment this CNN work it
better for all database that you have a
tested and I will show some results
using this method for the first
experiment I in the first experiment I
use it a fibrous database this is the
semi database data showing the video and
this database have 4000 image and chew
and chew class and each image has 16 by
16 the class are fibrous is an image
like this and no fibrous this is an
image like this and the first figure
shows the results or beaten a doozy the
CNN train it with the fibrous database
and I will call this method by approach
one and the second figured show the
results or beaten it using the CNN they
inception at work I will call this
approach I call this method by approach
to and in the first column you have the
Curie image ending the second call will
have the top five head rivet image as
can be see the results of each it up
attended for both approach are very
similar and oozing my laptop I computer
some methods of time and also I I will
test day and other system soon in the
time of the train to the approach one
was about three minutes this 20 process
was fast due to the number of the the
size of the image that is only 16 by 16
the time to the extraction of features
for the world database was nine seconds
for the approach one in 29 minutes for
the approach to and as home where total
a few minutes ago they approached you or
the inception network has a lot of
layers in the extraction of features for
this approach is longer is Israel at
that time to date obtained to head over
the top ten key image for a single Curie
image was four seconds with approach one
in 50 seconds for the approach to
in the second experiment we use it a
database with about 3,500 image in to
class abnormal cells and normal self
cells of cervical cells and each image
has head size of 100 by 100 and this
first figure shows the results using the
approach 1 and this figure shows the
results was in that brush tool and also
the results are beaten for both CNN's
was very similar the time of the
training process for the approach one
was 9 was 94 minutes and they the
increases inhalation with the fresh the
experiment was due to the size of the
image of the increase of the size of the
image in this example if image has 100
by 100 of size and in the fibrils
experiment each image is 16 by 16 that
are three factors that increases sharply
the time of the training process that
are the number of image the size of each
image in the number of class for the
database the time of the extraction of
features for the whole database was 48
seconds for the approach one in 23
minutes for the approach to and the time
for for evil dead of the top 10 image
for a fury image was five seconds for
that pressure 1 and 12 seconds for the
approach to now I will talk about the
the advantage and disadvantage of both
approached losing the results oh BTW
opportunity in the experiments the main
advantage of the approach one is because
the after the training process the
extraction of features is fast and also
the training process is Donnelly only
once another advantage is because for
the approach one each images have
presented only by 2 256 features however
they
a disadvantage is because for big data
sets with big images in several class
the training process is this low the
advantage of the approach to is because
each doesn't need it rain training
process and however the disadvantage is
because the extraction art features is
low also order at the disadvantage of
this approach is because each image is
represented by 2048 features now then he
will finish the presentation with the
next steps offers yet exactly because
the inception network has a lot of
layers and the structural features is
low then if you have mr. Foyle exactly I
say it's like I saved a csv file and
choose the choosing the next achieve a
process i computed the features in
saving their cv files and in the next
day in the next process i will use this
file I don't need you more to stretch it
the fix for the whole database the
images they need to be in a single
memory may be distributed in size right
now in it yes how's the paper
so it's a lot of information to cram in
the 30 minutes that's where we have
three of us here would be happy to
answer any questions after the
presentation and I'll finalize it with a
few ideas where we want to go from from
here definitely there is a lot of work
in terms of where these images will live
right now they're leaving in a laptop
and we're moving also the experiments to
a much larger system which the deaf box
we would like to also to put on a super
computing system as well but to make
sure this works of course we test on our
laptop first and that's how how it is
right now and we're very happy with the
results that we got so far our focus is
in scientific image database is so far
we did not have any alternative to sift
it through these large data sets that we
need to collect on a daily basis we do
want to learn the bass parameters
remember we mentioned oh we have these
ten metrics we have all these different
features which of them should i use
depending on my data set should you do a
brute force yourself selecting well if
you have a label data set then there's a
lot that the machine learning can do for
you turning through the best features
using methods such a few Durand rapper
techniques for selecting the best
features and the best techniques another
thing and we want to have a ways to
monitor our accuracy currently this is
steel in in pieces not really as a part
of the of the system itself all we do is
if you have labeled data we tell you how
many times you are making it right
that's all we have so far but you
eventually you could check well how many
epochs will be the ideal for my
convolution area network to perform the
best speed up while there are so many
things that we could improve in terms of
the speed up here and that has to do
both in terms of this signature
similarity calculation remember this is
embarrassed parallel there is no need to
do feature one and
then feature two and then feature three
those could be calculated and parallel
right that's one of the opportunities /
image and improve the ranking algorithm
remember we bring you the the best 10
there are different ways of doing that
to do this comparison right now we're
going through the whole database to
check which are the top 10 when that's
the question we could have prototypes
for each of those classes and compared
with the prototypes right if we have
supervised data sets and definitely
customized for different applications
that's when ciebie really strive when
you're you're working with microscopy of
cells then what you're going to be
querying with our other microscopy of
cells as opposed to faces or other
objects so with that we like to thanks
for your attention and we are hiring at
berkeley lab so if you're interested we
do have positions i currently have an
open position for a computer vision
postdoc expert so if that's the case
please talk to me if it's not the case
we do have positions across the
laboratory and across the division I'm
the computational research division and
if that's what you do or you would like
to learn more we have great
opportunities also at the berkeley
institute for data science you may want
to look for potential jobs or even
interacting with us we really open to be
working with you we have a consulting
free of charge so you may just land
there and see what what's going on share
your data with us and we can brainstorm
about possibilities we will be have to
take questions now thanks for your
attention
you